Mit dem projekt deep hat die nasa wirklich
sensationelles vor kleine sonnen sollen mit hilfe von laserstrahlen
extrem beschleunigt werden und ins nächste
sternensystem geschickt werden aber nicht nur das die mine raumschiffe werden auch bemannt sein jetzt sind tatsächlich die ersten
passagiere für diese interstellare reise gefunden und die sind selbst ein bisschen
Außerirdische welche lebensform es sich dabei handelt was durch sie erforscht werden soll und alles weitere
zu diesem spannenden nasa projekt jetzt endlich zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die schiffe sollen mit lasern angetrieben werden und damit extrem beschleunigt werden und trotz dieser, hohen
beschleunigung wird ihre reise zu unserem nachbar sonnensystem wohl über 20 jahre dauert seit rund 18 jahren
tüftelt ein forschungsteam von der university of california santa barbara an dem nasa projekt namens deep jetzt wurde öffentlich
dass wohl passagiere diese interstellare reise antreten werden schon ihre namen klingen irgendwie
Außerirdisch nematoden und tardi geraten vielleicht haben einige von euch diesen namen schon einmal, im biologieunterricht
aufgeschnappt die nematoden
Km/h, petit es elegant sind tatsächlich beliebte modell organismen
Im fachbereich genetik die fadenwürmer sind nur einen millimeter lange haben dafür aber wirklich einige unglaubliche talente beispielsweise sind sie in der lage
In dauer larven stadium mehrere monate zu überleben ganz ohne futter sehr viel krasser noch sind die zweiten wohl
zukünftigen nasa passagiere die ta vie geraden auch als wassertiere oder
bärtierchen bekannt und die haben quasi sogar schon diverse job erfahrungen gesammelt ohne schutz
Im luftleeren raum wurden sie bereits in die kälte und strahlung des alls geschickt und sie haben überlebt waren sind die perfekten kandidaten
Also die fragestellung des nasa projektes lautet kannte restliches leben wie wir es kennen
im interstellaren raum existieren doch das erste problem für die
Außerirdischen passagiere wird ja schon die anfahrt sein denn wie gesagt wird die reise wohl
20 jahre dauern das forschungsteam hat aber auch davor schon einen plan am start die tiere sollen in
der straße ist also eine art starre oder ruhezustand gelegt werden und dann regelmäßig
Aufgeweckt werden so könnte überprüft werden wie die passagiere mit den gegebenen umweltbedingungen
klar kommen wann die große reise losgeht steht übrigens noch in den sternen der chefentwickler
Findet blumen hat letztes jahr in einem technology review interview gesagt dass er nicht glaubt dass
Er die ankunft seiner mini raumschiff noch, erleben wird zitat. Ich bin jetzt 63 jahre alt und werde vielleicht noch
den start einer interstellaren
Sonne in 30 jahren erleben doch dann wird es noch einmal 24 jahre dauern bis daten von einem stern bei uns eintreffen zitat ende
Übrigens ist die nasa nicht alleine mit ihrer idee mini raumschiff in unser nachbar
sternensystem zu schicken mit dem projekt break schuster plant der russische milliardär yuri milner ähnliches auch hier soll an lasers einen impuls auf eine
weniges wenige gramm schweres sonnensegel also ein englisches anderes system wie bei der die berichten und auch hier
Steckt philipp louven dahinter wenn ihr in 54 jahren mehr über die nachrichten auf einem anderen sterne system erfahren wollt dann drückt mir
Hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
auf die glocke denn nur dann bekommt
er eine die tv-nachrichten
Wenn das video online geht hier geht es also hier geht es weiter mit der reise zu aliens nur 20 jahre zum nächsten stern
Mit mehr infos zum projekt break star schon sehr spannend und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran